e aí galera que aceite meu canal tudo
bem com vocês hoje estou aqui com meus
cabelos num movimento eu sei que você
então vou fazer algo que vocês querem é
dar a césar o que é de essência mas não
vamos fazer uma troca enquanto vocês
assistirem que vocês tanto querem se
exclui que gostei beleza
[Música]
toca o negócio aí
bush
[Música]
e se você gostou da volta da dancinha
clique gostei que isso ajuda demais dj
que sou eu mesmo só um pouquinho a
musiquinha só pra falar os shows 25 de
maio maceió 27 maior a piraquê lagoa 27
de maio natal rio grande do norte e 31
de maio novo hamburgo rio grande do sul
11 de junho marília sp 2 de junho o
vitória do espírito santo crédit lembrar
de licitar a 18 de junho em salvador
bahia 9 de junho e santana bahia 7 junho
católica não é na bahia a empresa bit
bastante difícil moça catarina 24 de
julho também tubarão paranaense no mesmo
dia se o fato do mesmo dia do topo de 28
de junho a raça do sal 29 de julho
bairro são paulo bairro sampaio 13 de
junho em ribeirão preto são paulo 1o de
julho são josé do rio preto são paulo os
ingressos neste site é que está aqui
obrigado eu digo você assistir esse show
porque eu estou fazendo porque esse pra
mim é um dos melhores shows e precisa
ver ao vivo enfim hoje vai falar sobre
diferenças e às vezes é difícil aceitar
vamos falar a verdade e muitas pessoas
tiveram que engolir que engolir meu
sotaque quando comecei a fazer vídeo é
porque o dia saiu uma matéria dizendo
olha que surpresa um dos canais que mais
cresce no brasil é nordestino olha que
surpresa eu fiquei surpreso porque o
ouro foi para o brasil ao todo mundo é
na matéria o sotaque não sei que horas
vou falar do sul tal como se fosse um
defeito meu caminhão porque às vezes
gírias osso táxis não entende que você
falar e nem entendi que eu farei isso há
23 anos atrás dele na época foi tentada
a pessoa é tão diferente assim eu
falando as coisas não é porque às vezes
não consigo identificar o sotaque eu
falei é conversa para o cara conversa
assim estamos conversando a lei ele
ignora de bb king falou pouco e
ignorante deveria ser mais falei égua
machucá-lo égua onde nego faz tempo na
fazenda de vovô ser de água e aí ouvi o
seu nome tem dia nem pediu para chegar
pra mim falar e aí mano firmeza hoje vou
dormir na sua casa tapa de parra falei
pode parar lá em casa pode machado
rastelo o inchado não vai poder para
leve meu amigo dos seus colegas só para
lógico que pode passar até hoje demora
só se aquela música eu te avisei novinha
pode parar falei com ela tá na moda um
pedreiro que é que foi a galera daqui
achava que eu falava errado e eu achava
que a galera daqui falava errado mas não
é cara isso
a diferença eu desci brasil inteiro
fazendo show cara eu vejo diferença em
todo lugar que eu vou eu fiz show na
bahia o cara depois do show chegou para
mim e falou por nêgo você é o barril do
brado velho aplicará estou gordo mesmo
tom parece um barril em dobro o meu deus
ninguém respeita não na verdade barril
dobrado a 1 foi um cara legal um cara
pois você é massa e outra palavra massa
e de janeiro fala pô valeu valeu valeu
valeu valeu ouro valeu aí valeu o pegar
uma onda valeu valeu valeu cheia também
pra vocês 3 6 7 8 9 e 10 10
agora pense que é só no rio de janeiro
que china não é manal xi também por me
ver no aeroporto ela manda um endereço
no nicho nunes tira uma foto com a minha
filha a mãe disso num nicho de juros era
mano isso não nos tirou ponto eo nunes
emoção na minha casa como uma galinha
isso não é defeito para isso se chama
diferença eu casei com a gaúcha cara
riscos e meio de namoro que a gente vai
aprender a se comunicar direito da
mulher o negócio e daí que eu não sei eu
não entendo a colocação do daee ela não
entendia o que era massa que falar ainda
em dia na primeira vez que falei com ela
vamos falar em fazer o que ele também
fazer um tempo deu a entender é o lanús
entendeu que é por tendeu é bom demais é
o tb né não pode faltar hotel e já
atendeu ao diferencial que atendeu ela
falou é uma festa falei porque não fala
festa no mundo deu o que falar a festa
que é festa é massa começou o que é mas
eu falei mas é uma coisa que não é pai e
disse pai né ai é porque se não for
massa é pai é o bom mesmo é que seja
massa é papo quando foi o pai a não ser
eleita pai né ela disse kerr pai e isso
é uma coisa que é massa massa pra gente
é legal é top e palha é ruim é massa é
massa pela massa ela perguntou de onde
foi que surgiu assim massa lei lá e
apareceu aí tava sei lá um médio nacif o
médico olhou pra mim e falou esse menino
é massa e com massa para ser ouvir os
outros falando eu falo até hoje massa
vai roubar nada venda e não quer que
falou e disse eu falei nada a ver e não
antes disso ela falou assim eu falei bar
nada a ver daí eu falei o que é barra
daí falei lá avaí pareceu isso eu acho
que eu nasci o médico olhou pra mim
falou o barça mas daí eu falei ah então
ba e daí pode agora o massa é errado não
pode falar ela falou marbá e daí tem
sentido eu falei tentem se
não tem na bíblia moisés falou ba
aproximar da iol até acertar esse
diálogo é de alcançar gaúcho alcançai
tipo assim paguei pra mim alcança esse
negócio alcança esse negócio está em
cima da mesa pessoa que tiver mais perto
vai pegar vai dar pra pessoa pra mim
alcançar é uma coisa que está alto tendo
pego aquele negócio ali que eu não
alcançariam na mesa me alcança e se
torne lei que alcancei vitória tal já
não é que eu não alcanço elisa tá na
mesa na altura do peito não entendeu que
eu estava discutindo a lei não pára e
não vou te fazer um dicionário aqui em
casa
a dança angelina a minha tangerina que o
nome eo nome é potente tangerino
angelina pra ela é bergamota motta/ae o
número de mota a lei o que obriga uma
nota a lei é tangível e na rafael não é
branca motta nós não tem cara de mega
moto bergamota nome senhora de ver a tia
bergamota falou ele também não tem cara
de tangerina falei quem não tem não hã
hã hãe ano tem o que é uma tragédia
humana então se não é isso aí tá na tua
frente no confusão agora é defeito é
errado não é é cada um tem o seu jeito
carioca é o que faz cada coisa sem
especial é defeito a diferença que faz
tudo ser especial minha cachorra é
formar diferente porque meu cachorro
agora é jean que agradou nada de amor é
meu deus eu não pensei é tanto amor da
minha vida aí apae demônio vem cá anda
aí a chamou pelo nome de batismo elas
nem todas essa diferença toda a
diferença quer ler essa é a regina
regina me lambe lambe mlab mlab regina
regime lambe-lambe agora não lamb não
amb
ela nem dois nem gostou do meu dói é
defeito não é defeito é cada um do seu
jeitinho e não solta pela mora onde eu
vou ter empenho dela não tem força não
consegue fazer nada regina como a casa
inteira amora cagando porque há uma
pilha palitos em um pequena regina a uma
bateria de carro é defeito não é defeito
cada um tem seu jeito especial cada uma
duas igual é igual a bolinha do toddy
não quer dizer que porque mistura e
ficar lá em cima
se é o melhor é ver a bolinha é defeito
ou eu vou logo nela fala assim não é
defeito o que torna o toddy mais
especial ainda não é viu quem cala
consente ou toma desse jeito porque
comigo ninguém pode se você que está
assistindo é alguma coisa que a galera
acha que é defeito em você é defeito não
é o que torna mais especial beleza o re
comigo-ninguém-pode pública contigo em e
todd não sei que abole melhor
se você gostou desse vídeo não esqueça
de clicar e gostei eu quero que você
comente aqui embaixo de qual estado você
é o que tem de mais diferente lugar onde
você mora tá muito obrigado você tenha
tido esse vídeo clipe gostei aí não
esquece um beijão é nós eo e foi embora
na coisa safar dessa menina lá coisa
safar dessa nem a coisa tá fazendo essa
nenê